have leads coming in, have seven business owners running Google ads, but none of them picking up
the phone. Daniel Kong, that's an interesting challenge. Here's a couple of suggestions.
Get a Google voice number. Use a call rail number. Try star six seven. Just do all kinds of different
things that you can do to get them to pick up the phone. Try sending them a text. Hey, I got this
job. I could say, I don't know, just try different things. If you can't get any of them to pick up,
that seems very, very interesting and very, very weird. But I would try a couple of those things
first, guys. We just got to get that attention, get them to answer. We've got to have a chance
at it. Of course, worst case scenario, you could always send an email. It's my least favorite option,
but yeah, you could always try a text message. Just don't give too much information away. We
got to give a reason for them to call you back.